ardeen muhammad was once a successful
farmer and trader
but he's been living like this for more
than a decade
this makeshift structure is why he's
trying to raise a new family after boko
haram violence uprooted his life he says
his chain of businesses houses and farms
all perished in a single attack in 2010.
i had more houses more farms more shops
and warehouses and kamala than everyone
else look at me now i can't even fend
for myself even the room i live in was
given to me rent-free by a former
business partner but with peace
returning i look forward to going back
to rebuild
italian
the boko haram conflict in northeastern
nigeria has displaced more than two and
a half million people forcing them into
camps
now the government wants to shut down
these camps by the end of this year as
reconstruction gathers momentum
this small pile of rubble is what is
left of the former school and home of
muhammad yusuf the founder of boko haram
this is why the group's ideology was
nurtured nigerian security forces
demolished the structures shortly after
the rebellion was put down in 2009 but
the movement grew even bigger and
continues to kill people and destroy
property in northern nigeria
an estimated 300 000 people have been
killed
six billion dollars worth of property
and facilities lie in ruins in borno
state alone
people have completely lost their means
of livelihood
many of our educational facilities were
destroyed
about 5000 classrooms are destroyed
about 250 health centers are destroyed
about
800 municipal buildings were destroyed
comprising of
traditional rulers
homes
police station local government
secretariats among others as thousands
returned to their old villages this is
what they find
new houses are coming up in communities
where 900 000 homes were destroyed
in a direct challenge to boko haram
whose ideologies against western
education and values hundreds of schools
raised down by the armed group are being
rebuilt and more students are enrolling
over 60 percent of our
budget
of our capital budget goes to
reconstruction rehabilitation and
resettlement and in terms of value of
money that has been spent
the amount is worth carrying
between
the nigerian army disability hunters the
police the bonus state government
for the last
10 years procured nothing fewer than
about 2000 vehicles
thousands of kilometers of roads that
have been bumped during fighting between
security forces and boko haram are being
fixed
here at maiduguri's biggest market
traders load up goods to neighboring
cameroon chad and asia as security
improves
farmers who couldn't access their lands
have returned to their farms after a
decade of disruptions
even hospitals that were not spared by
the armed group are back offering
services to the sick and wounded
but with boko haram still posing a
significant security threat
the restoration effort could still go
wrong
a reality that hundreds of thousands of
victims hope
will be avoided
ahmed idris al jazeera maiduguri
northeast nigeria